vous allez avoir une minute à vous avez
beau petit cool ah oui alors voici donc
des lettres et elle est là vous devez
trouver le faut l'avouer le plus long à
sa fiche et vous pouvez jouer alors nul
en est quand même à commensacq fils
merci j'ai le score moi j'aimerais oui
là j'ai trouvé
elle est plus rapide à l'asie mais
qu'une et montrer ce qu'ils ont écrit à
l'article on l'a trouvé ah oui oui oui
as les couilles alors tout le monde
alors excusez moi vous avez l'esprit mal
tourné parce que personnellement j'avais
lucioles j'avais lucioles et mes fiches
à à l'écran il ya donc deux nouvelles
lettres rien
[Rires]
et
salut c'est lyon s'est laissé gagner des
lettres délais maximaux voici donc
d'autres lettres on va jouer avec des
aides suivantes on va jouer avec daniel
moreau 1 daniel moreau trouvez moi une
minute
serhat un mot de 10 des vols alors être
pas dû l'être
alors c'est moi dès que c'est plus il ya
moins de monde de deal à trois mois ça
c'est fait allez-y alors pensé ce
qu'elle a trouvé à temps morales et
morale et morale et moraliser oui à lise
benina temps il est très très long à
roye grand oui on va où il passa web à
ses besoins et ceux qui n'ont pas trouvé
alors ouais non il n'ya pas deux alors
on va arrêter alors les régions
remouillé c'est quoi vont ils venir
mouiller mais sunu non remouillé non bah
pourquoi l'om rod laver corner ça peut
paraître ça marche au mouillage vers la
home n'est pas inversée pas mr effectué
l'emploi un objectif
alors il va alors très loin de ce qui
est bon c'est balla ça marche pas mais
c'est la vie ça m'a alors à la morue
très bien passé pas mal à sydney
papounet boureux
pensez y à berne à languibonou me
rappelle des visions de l'uia ce qu'est
le bébé ça aurait fait du bien c'est un
flamand c'est comme ça vous savez que
dans les principes dessous tous et que
vaut ce qu'on met des lettres et que ça
veut dire quelque chose
le niveau est très élevé vous dit quand
même parce que cette séquence est ce que
c'est les terres dh alors qu'il avait on
avait des moules beurrés mines audrey
merdique mr douillet est verrouillé ça a
merdé pas mal merci beaucoup
faut faire des progrès en l'air